hi
how are you everyone uh this is charlton
new uh an associate professor at the
university of connecticut
uh here i will talk about our recent
work on
developing crypto based quantum clear
analytics of south korean 2
so here's the outline of metadata talk
so firstly i will give you a brief
background on what we are doing and the
code landing
dynamics
and then i will introduce uh the old
creative technology which are developed
in our lab for source equivalent to
advanced detections
then i will present our digital one
start critical technology for
further quantification of the first
equivalent to variance
lastly i will present
our crispr on paper device for the
multiple gene detections of soft
equivalent to
variance
so here's a brief background and the
motivation so where we are interested in
this research topic
so as you know where we have this
version meeting
because there is a good landing pandemic
so a couped landing disease
is caused by a
colonial violence called the south
korean 2.
this
valence can spread a person to person
very fast and then now the covenanting
is the greatest
threat to global health global public
health
so there is a
clear need for developing a low cost a
point of clear dangerous device
for soft equipment to advance detections
so for the
first equivalent to advanced detection
so there are different
seo methods so one of the most
popular technologies is the lubric acid
based molecular detections
for the molecular
tankless risk they detect the specific
genetic information of the subsequent
two variants so this is one of the most
sensitive and this specific uh zyngrosis
approach uh for crude land 19.
so
among these are different
molecular technologies technologies
rt pcr technology is
considered a good standard essay for
source equivalent to advanced detections
a lot of hospital or clinic labs are
developing technology for south korean
to advance dangerously
but
for rtp cell technology so there are
some
elimination or disadvantage for point of
care applications
so it require wear print technician and
the expensive equipment so
it is not ideally for point of clear
applications
uh in recent
decades so
there's um
some new technology like exothermal
amplification technology up here
to replace the rtpcr technology
they can work at a constant temperature
temperature for the nucleic acid
amplification and the detections
but for the exothermic amplification
technology they also have some
disadvantage for instance
there is a non-specific amplification it
means uh you will easily get the false
positive signals
so uh
except for the exothermic amplification
the gene frequency uh technology also
appeared uh for the uh for the molecular
dynamics but it also require expensive
equipment
uh so it's not ready for quantum care
applications
uh in recent
three to five years so there's uh
emerging technology we call it crystal
technology uh for the nucleic acid
detections especially combine the
isothermal amplification with the
critical technology so we can achieve a
higher sensitivity and the specificity
detection of the
pathogens so
here is the
example for the
first cuban 2
valence detection by using the crystal
based
detector sc
so for instance so you what you want to
detect the uh the the work sample
in uh from patients so you extract the
nucleic acid uh from the fusion sample
then you can do the exothermic
amplification at 60 to 65 degrees like
this work they do the lamp isothermal
amplification then the uh to uh the
crystal based fluorescence detection so
we can use the lateral fluid strip
for the
for the visual detections so this is the
result for the lateral fluid strip
visual detection so without any uh
expensive equip equipment so you can
achieve the sensitive detection of south
equivalent to
variance
apart for this technology so there are
some
change or disadvantage
for instance so
for a crucible-based lubricant asset fc
it requires
multiple steps or manual operations such
a
pre-amplification or crispr detections
so
this operation is not ideally for
point-of-care application and they have
the high risk
of the carry over contaminations
another issue is uh for the
crisper-based nucleic acid detection
there is a lack of the quantitative
detection
especially for
absolutely quantitative direction of the
nuclear effect
then the also
is the lack of the multiple target
detection
so you cannot achieve multiple detection
of the
pathogens so this is some uh change for
current uh crispr with nucleic acid
detection
so to uh address this challenge so here
we propose a different essay
to uh to achieve the goals so first
technology we i will present is our
original critical
kiss travel a sc so we call it eight
crispr we adapt this technology for a
rapid and the sensitive direction of the
south proving to awareness
okay so here's the design and the
working principle of this build crystal
technology so uh for this technology we
combine the uh rpa exothermal
amplification and the critical risk
detection in one port so this is where
we called when volume
detections
and the
unlike uh previous uh research or
publications so here we uh propose user
two uh crispr cad only we call the dual
crystal with detection so these are two
things without any uh pen set
so this is an advantage for the design
of the uh getter only and then for our
ultra crisp sc uh we um can achieve a
visual detection uh without expensive uh
uh detection equipment
so uh here's the working uh principle of
this essay so first we do the
rpa as a thermal amplifications
then the amplicum from the rt
pcr rtrp amplification will indicate the
crisper detections and they produce a
very strong fluorescence so at this
point so you can do the visual
detections under the blue led or even uh
do the calorie magic detections without
any
equipment
so this is the basic principle for this
uh
crisp essay
so here's the design for our
get only for this old principle so here
we given
three are different together only who
are they only one and this year and two
uh we
don't have the prm set and for the uh
comparison purpose we also defend the cr
on e3
with the pen set
so firstly we compare the sensitivity
are for the single theory and the dura
theory uh
in our early crystal sc as you see
if we use the two theory without a pen
set
so we can achieve three copies of
kubernetes in detections
and the um if we use the single c only
with the pen set
so we only detect
the
3000 copies
so
so the sensitivity is much
lower compared
to feyenoords
and the interesting so for the
single theory with the pen set
for the high concentration samples the
signal
come up early then
the the only
without handset
nextly
we also
evaluate
the specificity for this iot crystal
which detects the source equivalent to
nucleic acid and the most
most proving and the south equivalent
and the human
human gene materials so we can
consistently detect the subscribing tool
only in the samples then
we also evaluate the
soft cuban tool only detection because
source equivalent to valence is only
balanced so here we take the synthetic
uh only
with our uh rt l crystal sc as you can
see uh we can account consist detect uh
five copies uh synthetic subscribing to
uh only so it means this assay can
achieve a higher sensitivity
and this specificity
so then uh we further uh detect
the
patient sample uh to evaluate the
feasibility of our
device for the clinical applications so
we test 28
quid 19 question sample
which includes eight positive samples so
as you can see uh in this uh real-time
curve so all each processor ports are
detected then we also um
to the end point visual detections uh
for the positive samples the for
instance will show up in the reaction
tube and for the negative samples it
does not
so then uh we want to further simplify
the uh
point of care thank goodness uh with our
ultra crisp fe
so here we just use the hand warmer so
this hand warmer is activated uh
uh bad air so
uh so and this uh hand warmer is really
cheap just
0.3 dollars so uh we i just put the
reaction tube uh of the old crystal on
this uh
hand warmer and they incubate
for
20 to 60 minutes as you can see
uh after 20 minutes for the positive
samples the flanges will let up and the
negative sample does not so when you
increase the
incubation hand for the positive samples
the for instance becomes stronger and
stronger so in this
case so you do not require expensive
equipment
you just use the hand warmer to the
south korean 2
advanced detections so this is ideally
for a point of clear applications
so this is our uh crucible essay for the
first equivalent to
detections
so next i will introduce our
critical based
point of care ankylosix devices
so there are two devices i will be
present so first device is our
digital one start
crisp sc
the second device is the left arm paper
for the multiple gene detection of the
source equivalent to
variance
uh so here's the uh digital one start uh
chris barclay so here
we use the commercial available uh
digital microfluidic device
for the
detections
so this is the uh working principle or
an event for our digital one start
critical fc
so
here we use the
zero priming exothermal amplification we
call it stamp as a thermal amplification
so this a technology similar like the
lamp i see it can work at 65 degrees for
the exothermic
amplifications
and then we combine this attempt as a
thermal amplification with crispr
detections
uh in our one start uh crisp fe and the
the big issue for this um combined essay
is that
for isothermal amplification is a work
at 65 degrees and for the crispr based
detections the optimized temperature is
37 degrees so there's a huge difference
for the
reaction temperatures so here we
optimize the uh pollution and they
combine this two reaction in one port
and after that so we
adapt the uh the 3d digital chip
for the
digital detection and the quantity
quantitative direction of the first
equivalent to valence
so here's the optimization for this
uh detection for different temperature
so we have incubate the reaction at a
different temperature like 48 degrees
so as you can see there's a new signal
will come up for the positive samples so
after
incubate the
reaction at
50 degrees so for the positive sample
the signal will come up
and the negative sample is ah does not
so when we increase the um
the temperature for the incubations so
after above
50 80 degrees so the secret
the signal of the positive sample does
not come up so it's so here we
uh optimize the temperature and they
choose 52 degrees for our one start
crisp ic in our
detections
so
after that so we further optimize the
incubation tank for our one star crisp
fc
so fortunately we can
extract the nucleic acid
from a position sample like the level or
a swap samples so
then we
introduce the extracts only
into the uh one start crisp reaction
buffers and the after that we
distribute the the reaction buffer in
the digital microfluidic device
so we incubate this device
at a different temperatures so as you
can see with the increase of the
incubation time so the
uh the
let up support
will increase
so after uh
120 minutes so the signal will saturate
edges so we compare
incompletion 10 90 minutes and 120
minutes so 90 minutes is enough for our
digital detections so here we choose a
90 minutes incubation for our teacher
one start crisp essay
so next
we also compare the performance of the
reagent preparation hand so as you know
you know for the sample preparation at a
room temperature so it takes some time
so typically if the tiger may be more
than 10 minutes
so the major concern for the uh
for the quantitative detection of the
nucleic acid is the uh the
pre-amplification at the roon
temperature so we compare the
performance of our uh one star
and the uh the ultra crisp sc so as you
can see uh
at a different um religion the
preparation hand so uh for our uh one
start crucible so there is no
no a green support uh sure off uh even
we are waiting for
720 minutes
at a roon term room temperature and the
for the
uh earthquakes of sc uh so even you know
after uh uh waiting for 10 minutes at
room temperature so you can see some uh
inflation support will show up so it
means uh for the
for the uh rpe uh crisp uplift uh
digital detections so they can
amplify the signal and the dna at room
temperature so they cannot achieve the
absolute
quantitative detection
so it will maybe over estimate the toxic
concentration and for our uh won't start
crystal fc so
they cannot so this is where we develop
this one start uh crystal sc for the uh
quantitative detection of the source
equivalent to variance
so then we also evaluate the specificity
and the sensitivity for our digital one
start uh crisp fc as you can see uh for
this test so only subscribing to uh
positive control can detect and the
other
first
pathogen
nucleic acid cannot and then we also
evaluate the sensitivity with this uh
one start uh essay
we can
consistently detect uh 50 copy uh per
megadeth in our digital one start
crisp essay
then uh we also uh detect the clinic
example to verify the clinical um
performance uh for our digital one start
uh crisp sc so here we have uh detects
35
clinical samples include 32 a swap
sample and three select samples so as
you can see for the negative samples so
there is no
green
support
sure off and therefore the positive
samples are so
they can
show some
green support means there's some nucleic
acid amplification so it's interesting
for the
uh higher 50 volumes samples
so as a circular volumes so it means the
coffee number is very high and is a
green support
lumber also is high and therefore the
low carbon numbers so the 50 volume is
large and is uh
the support uh will will be
left so based on this uh detections so
we can
do the quantitative direction with our
teacher uh won't start a crisp essay
then we also evaluate the performance of
the long uh extraction sample like this
level so the level is ideally for the
point of cure thank goodness
uh because this is a long invasive
test
so
so here uh we uh mix the celeb sample
with the uh phosphine two variants then
we incorporate the sample at 95 degrees
uh to lessen the variance to release the
nucleic acid
then we introduce the sample into the
digital microfluidic device so as you
can see
we can
detect the first qubin 2 advanced in
on-treat
select sample so so it means uh in the
future we can adapt this fc for the
lower the left sample thank you six
for subscribing to advanced detections
so this is our
teacher um one start uh creative essay
for the uh quantitative detection of the
first coming two variants
so
lastly i will present our left on paper
with microfluidic device for multiple
gene detections
so here's the design for our device so
for this device so there are
three uh they are fair uh full uh um
reaction chamber so for each chamber so
they have a different uh crispr and then
and they get only solutions so they
include the only p gene so this gene
detect is from the human
so this is the host keeping gene and we
also detect the enzyme and the f gene so
we have the black
blank control
so where we wanted to do the multiple
detections so for because for the first
equivalent to valence so firstly we want
to verify the sample uh is uh uh is
is
work well for the nucleic acid detection
so here we detect the the host keeping
gene so like the on is pg and they will
also take multiple engine and the s gene
from the first equivalent to advanced so
to achieve to improve the uh detection
accuracy so uh this is the design for
this um uh left on paper device so we
use the 3d printing technology
fabricates the
multiple r key of the reaction chambers
and we use the wax splitting technology
fabricated the paper based microfluidic
device as you can see
initially
for this
device so after you incubate
at 37 degrees so there is no for
instance so because there is no uh
amplification and the the valve does not
open in our
left arm paper so after um
40 minutes so for the positive samples
so you can see the strong lenses are in
the
crisper detection chambers so in this
case you can achieve a multiple
detections
with the single ch
samples
so firstly we evaluate the sensitivity
of the first equivalent to
detection in the reaction tube so here
we target uh two uh different gene from
the sub cabin two valence one is engine
another is s gene so first we do the uh
rtrt amplifications and then we
introduce the
rp amplifier into the crisper
chambers for the detections as you can
see
in this reaction tube so we can
consider detect
10 copies uh first kubernetes only for
the boost engine and the s gene uh so
this is a very sensitive
so after confirm uh this ac work aware
then we adapt
this detection on our microfluidic uh
chip
so
firstly we uh optimize the um the
surface constitution in our
paper-based microfluidic device so in
our device we have the
circular valve
so
this valve will regulate the
the reaction hang for the rp
amplifications so as you can see
with different
concentration of the circulars so the
above open time is different
for instance
for
five percent sugars the open
operation time for this uh
wolf is 5 to 10 minutes and
for the
50 minutes of 15 percent circles of
sugar's constitution the operation time
for this evolve is 20 minutes and for
our uh rpa amplifications so uh 50
minutes uh is enough so here we choose a
10 percent uh sequence
to prepare our
super vault in our paper based macro
first device so here's the real-time
detection for this
paper-based microfluidic device as you
can see
with different incubation time for
instance 10 minutes so there's no
presence because the valve does not
open and the crisper threat detection is
not
initiated
so after 20 minutes so the above uh is
open and you can see some forensics in
the positive chambers after 40 minutes
so the francis is very strong
in the uh possible samples
so after that so we further evaluate the
sensitivity uh for our uh left on paper
device for software ubuntu vent
detection so as you can see we can
detect uh 100 copies
for engine and the s gene is a little
worse
compare the
reaction tube uh maybe the reason is
that uh the uh paper-based material may
be potentially inhibit
the will
reduce the reaction efficiency of the
crispr detections
so here's the workflow for our um
paper-based microfluidic device for fast
cabin two advanced directions so here
you can collect the
swap sample and the less is the variance
then you introduce the perfect nucleic
acid into this microfluidic device
after 40 minutes incubation so you can
get the result so the whole process will
take
long hours for the
detections
so uh here's the demonstration for this
test so here we have test
20 21 clinical samples
so
for this a test for the negative samples
so only the hot keeping gene the only
teaching show the
flexor signal and the engine and the s
gene does not uh in our paper based
macro vertical device and for the
positive samples
so
the
the boost engine and the f gene shows a
fluorescence and the hot keeping chain
also shows the fluorescence
so
we can
detect what this r2 chain so for the
multiple detection of the first coupling
tool
so it can improve the detection uh
accuracy so this has it's uh comparable
with our
uh
pcr sc
okay so here i just make a brief uh
conclusion so
here uh we talk about the cooperative
pandemic and the crispr based molecular
diagnostic technology then i took about
our recent work on the one port
autocrescent i see for south korean two
detections
so then i have introduced uh two uh
crystal based point of care thank you
six device for subscribing to detections
one is a digital one start crisp assay
another is left on paper so multiple
gene detections of the source equivalent
to
variance
so here i want to thank uh my lab member
uh so
especially for uh dr kung and the uh dr
shinting
a lot of work was done by these two
gentlemen
so here i want to thank
my collaborators uh for this uh first
group into uh project so uh uh here i
want to thank um
this uh two uh
of uh three professor at uconn health
felony i want to thank the financial
support for this kubernetes
project
especially from the nh funding
so thank you so much i'm really happy to
take any questions